Yeah March big month for you man yeah
for sure you guys uh got the uh the The
Joint project which dropped on the 10th
he got the album was was this kind of
like the conscious decision to be like
yo it's your time right now like yeah
put out the runway man um and you know
shout out to Chad and everybody over at
drum work Conway for kind of putting
that together my man Dave over at Empire
you know what I'm saying like it was it
was like a conscious decision to say yo
let's just put out this project you know
we have been sitting on it for a little
bit pain provided profit let's put it
out and then you know why not just drop
the drop the album two weeks later
because it's like you know you already
have the floor you know what I mean 100
was there ever
um wasn't there supposed to be a drone
War compilation
yeah yeah and it still is um that'll be
coming I believe
um if if not April it'll be May so
that's on the way yeah it's on the way
so much drum work happening yeah man yes
it's time because you know we've been
we've been grinding for like the last
two and a half years for sure so it's
like you know now is like the perfect
time because people been waiting on it
you know what I mean like we all been
putting out our own little projects and
videos and different things making sure
that our presence is known but now it's
like nah like let's do the drum work
thing for sure uh abolish uncertainties
why the title so when I was thinking
about naming the album it was it came at
a time where I wasn't sure
um what was where I was going really in
life like I said like you know I just
quit my job and so you named this a
while ago yeah I named this a while ago
yeah this was uh back in 2020. I was
thinking of a name and so um you know I
was I was just always unsure man being
from Buffalo you know it wasn't a lot of
opportunities for people to get on with
music especially hip-hop you know what
I'm saying so you know when uh Griselda
you know they kicked on the door it was
kind of like well maybe I do got a
shot at this for real and then you still
got uncertainties though because you
know it how am I gonna do it I that I
wasn't sure of you know what I mean so
you know with this album I feel like I'm
really
um I'm taking whatever whatever like
chains and whatever uh it's almost like
cuffs that you have on your mind because
you can you can kind of enslave yourself
you know I mean you'd be a slave to your
mind because you start thinking so much
and then you got all these thoughts and
they just go and go and go and kind of
Psych yourself out yeah exactly so you
know I'm abolishing I was thinking about
it I was like yo I'm gonna abolish these
chains that I had on my mind
are the mental you know all that yeah
it's like abolishing slavery I should
say but yeah like take those chains off
of my mind because with this album this
is like my first real statement and you
know in the game you know what I'm
saying like that's how it really feels
who's on the album oh I got Conway
on there I got uh I got freeway on there
shout out my bro freeway man he came
through
um I got uh Jillian Haynesworth she's a
poet from the town okay I got my man
Terry King on there shout out my man
Terry King he's an awesome comedian and
I got Cody Sevilla she's an awesome
artist she she sings she raps she does
it all so when you hit freeway for the
future is it pretty like just you got to
pay for it I'll tell you how how I even
got that feature so
uh Beanie Siegel and freeway they both
came through Buffalo and they had a show
and I was at the studio that night and
um Conway was supposed to pull up and
come to the studio and they were gonna
pull up so they pulled up uh I'm sorry
uh beanie and free they pulled up and um
we was just sitting in the studio just
vibing and so I met DJ Coles he he was
like yo start playing your album yeah
and so you know beanie and uh free they
came in the stool and Kai never he never
came through sounds about right
uh bro came you know what I'm saying
they came in the studio
and uh you know I'm playing all my all
my records from about some certainties
that I had so far and uh I got this
record on there it's called out here
that came on and the flow that I use on
there is just crazy
it's almost kind of like some freeway
right you know what I'm saying he's a
big inspiration to me for sure and so uh
you know the record comes on and I just
see him so he's sitting in the corner
I'm sitting in like the middle of like
the studio he's sitting in the corner
and I'm watching him like his whole
reaction is just like yo this showing
this crazy like you know what I'm saying
going back and forth and um you know the
song goes off and I'm like yo bro like
it's room for you on there he's like
well I'm like yo there's room for you on
that record like I see you over there
vibing like you know hop on it man you
know what I'm saying like he was like yo
running back so we played it back he was
like yo let's do it so immediately like
I'm like yo my man Tony boy will say I'm
like yo Tony boy load up the session
let's get it he did his verse right
there on the spot it was love